es el día 500 de la invasión a gran
escala de Rusia a Ucrania y son 500 días
demasiados para una población que está
Sobreviviendo no solo la invasión de su
territorio sino también varios crímenes
de guerra por parte rusa entonces
después de todo que pasó este año fui a
preguntarle a la gente aquí en kiev como
creen que la guerra evolucionará
es muy difícil de vivir Cuando estamos
bajo bombas cada noche oramos para que
esta guerra se acabe lo antes posible
creemos en nuestras fuerzas armadas que
son nuestros Ángeles custodios gracias a
ellos la guerra por fin terminará
es difícil Primero aquí entonces aquí
y estás cansado pero nuestras tropas
están más cansadas
[Música]
son altibajos un día estás bien otro día
es horrible está sentado de nuevo en el
sótano o cualquier lugar pero en general
estás bien Te estás acostumbrando a todo
está bien
y Para apoyar la contraofensiva a los
Estados Unidos anunció
militar más armas para Ucrania y por
primera vez también
enviará municiones de la sino algo muy
controvertido pero también algo que la
población ucraniana que cada día pierde
a sus soldados y también a sus civiles
en ataques de cohetes en
infraestructuras civiles y a veces más
lejos de la muy lejos de la línea de
frente pues la población ve en Estas
armas como una necesidad que la gente
sabe que de momento las fuerzas rusas
tienen más soldados y más armamento más
armas que las fuerzas ucranianas y con
bombas de Erasmo que ya utilizan ambos
partes en esta guerra pues tanto Ucrania
como el occidente esperan acelerar el
éxito ucraniano en la contraofensiva